avec lui quatre autres restaurateurs
situés autour du canal de l'ourcq ont
écopé d'une fermeture administrative de
leur établissement pour la patronne de
ce bar tout a commencé avec une première
visite des forces de l'ordre le soir de
la fête de la musique mon établissement
est fermé depuis
jeudi je crois depuis jeudi pour
fermeture administrative qui était
arrivé parce que nous avions soit disant
pas respecté toutes les règles pour
empêcher la prolifération du thé vide
pour cette restauratrice pas question de
ne pas respecter les règles sanitaires
mais selon elle aucune autorité ne lui
aurais donné d'avertissement est la
fermeture administrative serait donc
tombée comme une première sanction c'est
à dire qu'on est une mesure de peines
capitales avant d'avoir eu une âme ne
serait-ce qu'une amende jeunes il se
peut que de temps en temps on n'est pas
fait les choses correctement ça peut
arriver ça peut arriver on c'est un
métier très compliqué en plus pendant la
fête de la musique ça a pu arriver
d'ailleurs c'est arriver à tout le monde
dans tout paris franchement ce que les
patrons d'établissements situés autour
du canal souhaite aujourd'hui c'est de
la communication est un réel échange
avec les autorités une réunion était
d'ailleurs organisée ce jeudi avec la
mairie du 19e arrondissement et des
représentants de la police dans le 11e
arrondissement cette fois rémy lui aussi
fait face à une fermeture administrative
la deuxième en moins d'un an fermé
depuis sept jours et pour une durée de
trois semaines
ils accusent encore le coup nous on
était au courant mais les clients ne
sont pas en quoi on fait de tout
protocole sanitaire que l'on nous impose
on a
on n'a pas non plus forcément le pouvoir
de l'appliquer comme il faut et c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que la police quand
ils viennent c'est au lieu d'être dans
la pédagogie et dans la proche plus
cordiales ses dires est ça a été direct
une approche sous forme de pressions de
menaces selon la préfecture de police
depuis le début de l'année 420
établissements se sont vu sanctionné par
une fermeture administrative